Film Courage: Should a writer seek out a manager
or should they wait until
the manager seeks them out?
Peter Katz, Story Driven CEO: I think that
they should seek out a manager for sure but
I do think that there's effective ways to
do that for instance seeing in the roster
is there somebody that you have a personal
relationship to so you could go through
ideally a friend who may be repped by a manager
that could be helpful sorry so you said a roster
so a manager might have a multiple clients that
are that they work with and one of them might be
the friend of a writer who's unrepped and then
they just might just go to somebody in that
who that manager reps and a writer or whoever and
then just say hey I love to get my work to your
manager could you make an introduction so that's a
way to do it another way to do it is you basically
just go go through just an email you have
an email query letter where you just send
it and I think that they just need to be
really simple hey my name is such and such
I have a science fiction script I would love
for you to check it out here's the log line
if you're interested I'm happy to sign a script
release just no one just wants to get exposed a
bunch of material legally so just saying hey I'm
open to sign that keep it simple that's great
that's all that's a very simple email and ideally
you research the managers because I don't really
work with a lot of purely comedy clients it's just
not my it's on my wheelhouse and sometimes people
just will be you're a manager but they don't see
that of a specific curation so I think you really
need to know who you're contacting or else you're
wasting your time and I think that there doesn't
need to be a whole narrative to that email
it needs to be something that you could just
pick up your iPhone and just read it and go
okay do I this log line does that interest me
because sometimes I get these emails are super
long and I don't have a lot of bandwidth so for
me it's just it's almost diminishing returns on
making it too wordy it's almost better just to say
my concept is so hot you're going to want to read
the script it's going to be you're just going to
read it and you're tell me more and that's enough
but sometimes you get too much information and I
think that it's not the the right way to move
forward because it's just as confusing because
you're what did this person want who are the it
just becomes more about it if it's here's an idea
let's talk and I think that's the
the key to do is just keep it simple
what is a script release some type of
paperwork that they signed that so you're
not connected to their script if you somehow 10
years later have a slightly similar project or
it's just it's it's customary for almost all
managers to have some level of protection for
being exposed to new work so it releases you
of liability in case they feel that there's
another script out there similar to their I
guess I mean it's just normal I mean whatever
any way to frame it I mean it's just no one wants
to get a bunch of scripts sent to them and then
somehow is your connection to other materials
just keeps it simple it's just a professional way
when you're exposed to new work and just
smart for any manager to not just get random
emails or scripts so you know someone's not
really familiar with the businesses if they
start by emailing you their script they should
always be clearly open to signing that release
at what point should a writer reevaluate whether
they're ready to approach a manager or an agent
I don't I think that ideally they have a body of
work that speaks to their voice so let's say they
write in the romantic comedy genre if they have
a few scripts that really are reflective of who
they are then why not I think they shouldn't try
out the different steps to getting a rep I think
it's valuable now if someone's not really clear
on what they want to do and they're still kind
of discovering what gets them excited and maybe
they should just kind of have fun and make things
and then kind of find their their voice later and
there's no pressure to have a rep you don't need
one as a creator you could just do your own thing
but I think it's valuable when you have a sense of
what kind of creator you want to be what genre
you want to work in who do you want to collaborate
with so the more specific you get about what
you're passionate about is probably the time where
maybe a rep could be valuable how common is it for
a manager to part ways with their client I mean I
think it's case by case I don't think there's a
frequency or a normal way to do it or where it's
more or less given the manager there's not I guess
a way a framework where you could point to this
is what's typical but I just think that in general
people who are working together on a regular basis
should have they can't always have a shared
Vision that's not I mean nobody you work with
in any profession is always completely aligned
but I think that it has to be in the in a
certain level communication or there's a mutual
respect and the paths that you've embarked on
are accepted and ex and they excite you you and
your collaborator versus a huge Schism in the
sense of strategy so yeah I mean it's just case
to case I think you just have to work with people
that gets you excited and get you passionate so I
think that's the most important part and whether
or not there's a departure or they're not I mean
that's fine you really have one life to live you
want to enjoy who you work with sure because
there can be people that are they're brilliant
in what they do and then maybe temperament wise
they're not a match or vice versa there could be
people that as you said earlier you want to hang
with but maybe talent level they're not there yet
I think that you just want to work with
people that you believe in and and they
have to believe in you too so there
that's a collab it's the collaboration
and that there's there's going to be challenges
in all facets of the business but you're fine
with them I said it's all about adaptation so can
you work together as everything shifts and you
have to keep coming up with new ways to find the
win because that's what we want to do we want to
push to go forward you want to keep
moving we want to keep progressing
and I think that's the goal is that the people
you're working with have that the same vision
to lead to being a successful filmmaker and
I think that same with you as a manager you
share the success with your clients something you
feel the winds too so I think that the question is
do your client and you have a have that
partnership that's meaningful and if there
is problems and either of the person doesn't want
to work together that's fine they could work with
somebody else or vice versa it's not a tragedy
it's just you have to work with people that you
find it a fulfilling profession to be part of this
team and that's what that's what matters is that
at the end of the day you didn't just sell the
project and you feel good you that you what the
person's about you what you you really enjoy the
the getting there it's not just that one sale it's
the the communication was in place you guys you
get excited about the same movies so I think
that it's fine if relationships part because then
maybe there's a another rep who connects with them
in a better way so it's not about just collecting
random people it's about building successful teams
and it's great to have belief in people but
unfortunately in the real world people will
let you down and maybe they don't try to maybe
it's not intentional but have you ever had to
have a conversation with someone that says I
need you to be more on point or we had this
meeting and you didn't show up you don't have
to give me specifics as to who someone is but
where they weren't holding up there into the
bargain and you had to have quote The Talk
honestly no I don't want to have that talk
I mean I think that there is a period where
you're talking to a potential client and you just
have to be honest with them about how you to work
and maybe you talk to their collaborators
about their experience working with them
and just get a sense of what's important and
when what's important to a collaborator and
they know your values I don't have issues about
performance so it's not somebody is slipping is
that we've already kind of got through it in
the initial introduction and and teaming up
okay what if someone has some dry
periods in their life where they're not
creating anything would you retain them as a
client I mean everybody has to work their own
way there isn't it's not a mechanical process
it's not they're making widgets is that it's
deeply personal to tell a story it's not something
that you could just turn into a system where you
could just do a paint by numbers process and
if you could it'd probably be a terrible movie
if that's not what I want they might have to
take time so when there's a collaborator and
they're hey I need some distance to kind of
come up with an idea or the work on a project
that's fine I have plenty of clients that are in
the mix of something new so the only area where
that could be problematic and I haven't dealt
with that personally but if somebody is hired
to do a job and then they can't execute on it
that's where that becomes a problem not when they
need time to write a new spec it's when there's
a contract sign and money has exchanged hands and
somebody's paralyzed that could be an issue for
sure but it's not a to me it's not a big deal if
a storyteller needs to sit back and watch movies
live a little bit run around do different things
and then just lock in to a vision for a project
my brother's a filmmaker and I see him sometimes
he'll have to walk into a museum or he'll
do something or he'll go somewhere and then
he'll get his mind activated so I've seen it
growing up and my dad is also an author he's
written some historical novels he needs to
just kind of get that groove so it's fine to
me I don't have an expectation that a person
has to constantly be churning out material
they whatever they need to get the ideas
building and moving forward is fine with me
as an advance on a book and they
have a contractual obligation to
turn in some type of pages at a certain
time and they haven't you've never had
to deal with no and then you're calling and
there's no return calls and you never had to
face that no the when the when the contract is
signed I've had clients just get to work it's
not precious at all they just do their job and
I know sometimes you'll see movies this author
who's totally out to lunch and not in the game at
all and then their agents calling or whatever but
for pages no I haven't dealt with that they're
they're working on a project or professionals
and they're delivering on time okay so you haven't
had any scenes of Factotum movie (2005) or Barfly
movie (1987) where you have to go and pull
someone out of the corner bar and get them
in front of the typewriter no not at all it's not
that unfortunate it's not that exotic it's not a
movie it's just kind of this do their thing
if you're hiring somebody in any profession
good okay sounds you have a good intuition
as to who you take on so yeah definitely.